well aaron rodgers isn't necessarily
decrepit but lately he has been looking
like a guy who's come in from about nine
months at sea trying to chase down a
giant marlin here's rogers after the
green bay packers lost at the san
francisco 49ers in the nfc championship
game and he was surprisingly upbeat
about the future in green bay that was
then this is now here's rogers back in
january
as we move into the off season now
the reliance is on
guys doing their responsibilities
and doing their part to be ready for
next season
and who knows what can happen i mean
there's
it's a long year
but
this one will always be special because
it became fun again and with brian
adding pieces
as he did this off season and we'll
continue to do
you know this i said it last week the
window was open for us
and that's the exciting thing
oh he uh he continued to add pieces for
sure he added some pieces big cat
mike i'm not gonna make fun of his beard
because i am on that path with uh what's
going on no haircut no beard i know i
see you're still getting a haircut but
yeah he uh i have not had a haircut i
haven't had a haircut in six weeks i
haven't had a haircut in six weeks it's
just gel copious amounts of gel i'm
telling you i haven't had a haircut in
six weeks
yeah oh okay i don't believe that but
let's talk i don't care if you believe
me or not it's the truth
i it would be so so great after the dak
prescott thing if someone caught video
of you at you know the barber shop in
west virginia oh my gosh if i could root
for one story this year but let's let's
talk a little aaron rodgers because i
haven't seen you since the draft
obviously this was the first topic here
uh
it's it's crazy really even a week you
know removed that the packers didn't do
anything to try to help themselves next
year when you have a window with a
quarterback like aaron rodgers and even
if he's taking a step back which he
probably has because he's not the same
like mvp aaron rodgers it doesn't matter
you have this window and you're
basically punting by getting redundant
positions both at the quarterback and
the running back it's crazy it really is
well and what really stunned me was the
comment from gm brian gudekunst after
rounds two and three when they didn't
draft a receiver i mean they were the
team most likely to take a receiver in
the aftermath of trading up to get a new
quarterback no receiver in round two or
three no receiver at all but after the
second day of the draft goodikoon said
that
they want to set everything up to go
through the running game and big cat i
think what happened is they went out to
santa clara got the crap kicked out of
them by the 49ers and that running game
and matt leflore the coach of the
packers emerged from that experience
saying
we need that not we need a better run
defense or we need a more dynamic
passing game
we need what they have in the running
game and that's going to be our focus
and that's the moment that the switch
flipped for the packers we found out
about it last week it's been percolating
for weeks and now they begin to
implement the plan so not only did the
49ers beat the packers soundly that day
they also kind of broke their brains a
little bit and forced them to lay the
foundation for an eventual divorce with
aaron rodgers
which that part is crazy to me to say we
need that running game the running game
that kyle shanahan has one he he has a
running game that's unlike anyone else
in the nfl like maybe you could say the
ravens but what kyle shanahan is able to
do that's more like if if you're the
packers gm and you say we need that well
guess what you need to go hire kyle
shanahan no it's the coach it's the
coach who wants it though the coach
wants to be that's the thing shanahan
can do it so matt leflore wants to show
i can do it too it's basic coaching
rivalry and ego right and i have a hard
time believing that anyone could copy
shanahan's run game to the level of
shanahan and then two
kyle shanahan has jimmy garoppolo who's
a fine quarterback but he's not aaron
rodgers and that's just speaking
honestly right
he's not aaron rodgers so why you
wouldn't play to your strengths
especially when you don't know how many
more years you're going to have what
like the old saying in sports flags fly
forever if you don't put it all in when
you have the chance to win a
championship if you're constantly saying
let's play for the future let's play for
the future it's
that will drive a fan base crazy and i
love it because i love that they picked
jordan love i think it's a ridiculous
pick in that spot but
it's definitely one of those picks that
we won't know if it's good for a few
years and it's almost rooting for aaron
rodgers to be out the door sooner than
later
i think in a roundabout way the packers
organization looked at what the team did
last year and going 13-3 and recognized
this team isn't nearly a 13-3 team i
remember being very stunned a few weeks
ago when one of the oddsmakers set the
over-under for wins for the packers this
year at eight and a half
and i don't know maybe they had a
crystal ball at the time because after
the draft i'm thinking maybe it is more
like an eight and a half win team not a
13 or a 12 win team but they
overachieved last year matt lafleur
picks up a lot of equity he's got some
poker chips he can he can spend now and
i think between leflore and gouda kunst
taking a little bit of that political
capital and pushing things toward having
a team that will be better over the long
haul that's what they're thinking i'm
not saying i agree with it i'm saying
that's their mindset that they think
it's better over the long haul to lay
the foundation to have a team that has a
different focus than to just try to get
that one last piece that's going to make
the difference between getting destroyed
by the 49ers and somehow getting to the
super bowl and winning it did they they
must have concluded we're not that one
piece away from winning it all with this
team
uh by the way i just did a french press
on tv i don't know if you saw that that
was fantastic to me i agree with you
mike i understand the thought process
that the packers have it actually is the
correct one in terms of the worst time
to go looking for a starting quarterback
is when you need one right teams that
are always thinking a couple steps ahead
they're the teams that have long term
success so the the thought process is
correct
where i don't understand what the
packers did when they took aaron rodgers
aaron rodgers was going to should have
been a top pick that slid down the draft
board remember how the dominoes fell and
there was 10 to 15 spots there where it
was like wait we're doing the math and
none of this works out he's going to
keep free falling that was a different
situation where if you're the packers
you say to yourself we have to take this
chance because the value is too great
jordan love nice guy you know i i i
he's he seems like a nice guy he seems
like he has some promise but he didn't
fall down the draft board if tua was
there at 23 or whatever they took jordan
love that's a totally different
conversation after the draft where the
packers can get on the podium and say we
saw a guy that was completely in the
wrong spot in the draft board the value
was too great to not pass up but in this
case it's the exact opposite where it
seems like they almost reached for a guy
that was probably going to go 31-32
to get that fifth year and they traded
up for it and they have aaron rodgers
yeah that's exactly what brett favre
said wednesday on siriusxm nfl radio
because the word that he summarized the
entire situation with was
disrespect and farv spoke to rogers
rogers hasn't said boo he hasn't said a
word he has been silent for a week but
he spoke to farve and then farve went
out and spoke to rich eisen and to
siriusxm nfl radio after speaking to
rogers so farve
is saying things that he gleaned from
that conversation and he made that point
it would be different if one of the top
quarterbacks fell down into your lap
like it did in 2005 when the packers
were already
worn out with this annual brett favre
william won't i retire nonsense they had
to be ready and here aaron rodgers fell
into their laps they went out at a time
when aaron rodgers had said repeatedly
he wants to play into his 40s and he
wants to finish his career with the
packers he said it over and over and
over again
and they trade up they give up a fourth
round pick to make that jump from 30 to
26 so they've got a first round pick a
fourth round pick a second round pick a
third round pick all devoted to
something other than what's gonna help
aaron rodgers win now and yeah it is a
slap in the face it is a cold splash of
water or a face full of french press
like you just uh created i'm used to the
whole coffee thing on tv sims is always
pouring it and drinking it while i'm
talking so i'm very impressed but
anyway i pressed on it yeah that's good
but but anyway uh yeah it's it's it's a
bad situation and you know packers fans
want to plug their ears and say they're
not listening or they want to just stay
in the denial phase of the five stages
of grief for as long as possible but the
reality is
aaron rodgers will make his
displeasure known one way or another
either internally externally or both and
everything he says is going to be
analyzed carefully by us and everyone
else to see what he's really thinking
and when he makes his move to get out of
green bay
okay let me ask you just this mike do
you think there is an element where the
media is overreacting in advance
expecting aaron rodgers to do something
and yet he has not done anything yet he
has not done anything yet or do you
think that we are just basing this all
on what we know about what you know his
past experiences the mike mccarthy thing
didn't end well and the fact that he had
that press conference saying i need a
wide receiver in a
like historic wide receiver class so do
you think we're being unfair to the
entire situation expecting the worst or
are we just doing what
it seems like it's going to all roads
lead to
yeah we are connecting the dots that are
right in front of our faces it's it's
a natural conclusion based on everything
we've seen and heard and experienced and
understood about aaron rodgers over the
past several years and he's already kind
of doing it to the extent that he did
speak to brett favre he didn't have to
talk to brett favre he didn't have to
take his call he didn't have to open up
to brett favre it's clear that he did
favre said on sirius aaron do you ever
look around and say i feel like the odd
man out and aaron said yeah
and that was a reference to the fact
that everything around them has changed
from the standpoint of gm and coach
everything's different at some point
you're the cheese that's standing alone
and that's where aaron rodgers is now
and that's where favre was then and i
think it's telling that rogers would
have even spoken to farv in the
aftermath of this because farv is the
guy the one guy on the planet who can
relate to what rogers is currently going
through so yeah i think that and and
sims and i talked about this yesterday
the one weapon that the packers have in
all of this is the media
and to the extent that rogers is acting
up behind the scenes if they start
leaking that and painting him as a bad
guy because i think he cares far more
than any other franchise quarterback
about how he's perceived and about how
he's criticized farv didn't care far
when farv decided he was coming back he
happily was the villain i'm doing
whatever the hell i have to do to get
out of green bay i'll show up i don't
care i'll do whatever i have to do i
want to play you have to deal with me
rogers isn't going to want to deal that
deal with it that way so he he it
actually may be maybe the packers are
operating five levels ahead of where
rogers is maybe the packers know that no
matter how upset he gets
he's not going to want to be perceived
as the villain in this and he's going to
bend over backwards to say all the right
things and do all the right things and
as i say that i'm thinking
rogers is not going to be able to pull
that off even if he wants to his
frustration is going to come through at
some point i don't know mike i i'll
disagree on one point there if the
packers start the season and they're not
playing well and rogers and and guys are
dropping balls and guys are getting
injured and their wide receiver uh
you know position gets depleted quickly
i think aaron rodgers will have a lot of
leeway with the general public
especially packers fans if he's if he
gets in front of a podium and says i'm
trying i'm trying with these guys and it
ain't easy and we had the chance to get
you know studs in here and we didn't do
it
there's a point where you got to stop
short though that's the key
the first part of it yeah i'm trying i'm
doing everything i can i'm doing
everything i can to try to help this
team win i want to win now you know
there's a way to do it
that isn't crossing that bridge saying
hey these
jerks didn't go out and get me the help
i needed you can lead the horse right up
to the edge of the pond and i think that
that's where he's got to be careful
because there is a way to do it where
you win
the mob in your favor i mean this
ultimately is going to be
a fight for the hearts and souls of the
green bay packers fans it's kind of like
what went on in new england everyone was
scared to death within the patriots
organization that when the dust settled
on tom brady's relationship with the
team
the organization was going to be blamed
robert kraft was going to be bane bill
belichick doesn't care if he gets blamed
and he's the one who's taken the blame
and you know what the world keeps
spinning nobody cares and i think that's
the other side of it all of this is kind
of overblown now it's easy because the
patriots fans have six super bowl rings
to take solace in but th this could end
up being a situation where the fan base
is weaponized and uh it comes down to
who plays it the right way
to get the fan base to point the finger
at the other side
yeah absolutely and we see it all the
time in sports i mean usually the
players don't win but
it is
that apparent drafting a quarterback and
a running back in a draft that had 10 12
wide receivers deep that's that is it's
hard to argue anything besides like they
didn't get him immediate weapons so he i
feel like he's already gotten a little
bit
of the fan base and the general public
being like hey this is kind of screwed
up because he needs someone in later in
his career
well and since aaron rodgers is a big
fan of the office he can relate to this
this is essentially a situation where
they have hidden andy bernard's phone
with the rock and robin ringtone and
they are going to mess with him in the
hopes that he eventually punches the
wall and if he can refrain from punching
the wall he potentially wins this
and and he ends up finishing his career
with your chicago bears which i'm
actually kind of rooting for i know
i know you are
i know you are and i don't but here's
here's the thing though mike zimmer the
vikings coach had the perfect quote in
the aftermath of the packers taking
jordan love last thursday night they
asked him about he said i hope aaron
rodgers retires i mean that's you know
yeah these guys don't want to deal with
aaron rodgers and that tells you all you
need to know about whether or not aaron
rodgers still has it it may not be there
a year or two from now but he still has
it right now
yes that's a good quote and i agree he
should retire all right we're gonna
enjoy his money
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports